today on the matt wall show new
revelations shed more light on andrew
cuomo's disastrous decision to send
infected covet patients into nursing
homes in new york
the scandal's even bigger than we
thought we'll talk about that today also
five headlines including dave ramsey
getting himself into trouble
by criticizing the stimulus spills but
does he have a point and in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss
the backlash against a film critic who
committed the sin
of critiquing an actress can't do that
as a film critic plus i'll read my
youtube comments and much more today on
the matt wahls show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know if 2021 has taught us anything
so far it's that you need to be using a
vpn
you don't have to give big tech websites
access to your data you might think that
that's inevitable that you have to do
that but you don't and why should you
um i choose to protect my online
activity by using expressvpn
ever wondered how free to access social
media companies make all their money you
might you might
think well advertisements and that sort
of thing well no the main way they do it
is by tracking your searches your video
history and everything you click on
and then they sell your valuable data
that's the way they're making their
billions
when you use expressvpn you make your
online presence
anonymous by hiding your your ip address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and more difficult to sell to
advertisers what's more expressvpn
encrypts 100 of your data
to protect you from eavesdroppers on
your network
and the expressvpn app couldn't be
easier to use here's all you have to do
i'll tell you the whole process i'll
lay it out for you you tap a button on
your phone or computer and then you're
protected it really is as simple as that
so
take back your online privacy with the
vpn that i trust
at expressvpn.com walsh
by visiting my link you'll get an extra
three months of expressvpn service for
free
on a one-year package again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh expressvpn.com walsh to protect
your data today
now as far as we know 15 000 people
have died from covid in new york nursing
homes
as far as we know emphasis on that part
of it the number is already much higher
than the previous figure which it turned
out was
being underreported by about 50 we could
probably assume that the actual number
is higher still
but even pretending that the numbers at
this point are accurate 15 000
is a staggering figure how did it get so
bad
how could so many die especially when
they were already ostensibly isolated in
care facilities
shouldn't that have made them more
protected instead of more vulnerable
well the how has been coming into
sharper focus lately
and some revelations this week
especially have helped to reveal
the the magnitude of this scandal in new
york first
the ap reports based on records that it
obtained it says
uh that quote more than 9 000 recovering
carnivorous patients in new york state
were released from hospitals into
nursing homes early in the pandemic
under a controversial directive that was
scrapped amid criticism accelerated
outbreaks
the new number of 9056 recovering
patients
sent to hundreds of nursing homes is
more than 40 percent higher
than what the state health department
previously released and it raises
new questions as to whether a march 25th
directive from governor andrew cuomo's
administration
helped spread sickness and death among
residents a charge
the state disputes okay nine thousand
that's
nine thousand people carrying a deadly
virus
a virus known to especially infect and
kill the elderly and carrying it
right into nursing homes keep in mind
that we knew on march 25th
that the elderly are most vulnerable to
chronovirus it cannot be claimed
claimed that cuomo and his
administration didn't realize what they
were doing
or didn't understand the implications
one of the first established facts about
the coronavirus
was that it hits the elderly heart and
that it hits kids
hardly at all those were the two things
we knew about it
right away those are maybe the two maybe
the only two facts about the chronovirus
that have not changed
and yet leaders like cuomo responded by
shutting down schools
and opening up the nursing homes to
covet
why was this done i mean what was the
reason
or at least the stated reason well the
ap says this
the cuomo administration's march 25th
directive barred nursing homes from
refusing people just because they had
coven 19.
it was intended to free up space in
hospitals
swamped in the early days of the
pandemic it came under criticism from
advocates for nursing home residents and
their relatives who said that it had the
potential to spread the virus in a state
that had
at the time um had the nation's highest
nursing home death toll already
okay free up space so they had they had
no choice but to send covet patients
into the nursing homes
effectively condemning thousands to
death because the hospitals were swamped
overflowing at capacity they say
well that's strange um it's strange when
you consider this reading from a usa
today article published on april 23
2020 it says the naval hospital ship
usns comfort is set to leave new york
city
city's harbor after it floated for three
weeks mostly empty of patients
projections about the spread of the
carnivores sent new york state
scrambling to increase its hospital bed
capacity
by more than double its 53 000 limit the
federal government was called in to
convert spaces like the
jacob javits center in manhattan to
overload into overflow hospitals but a
month after shutdown efforts
that capacity hasn't been stretched to
its limits
comfort and its 1 000 hospital beds
sailed into new york late last month but
was under scrutiny for being sparsely
used
of four overflow hospitals built in the
state
only the javits center has taken of
patients so far according to state
officials okay that again
april 23rd 2020. the hospital ship had
been in the harbor for three weeks at
that point
the directive to send coveted patients
in into nursing homes because of
overflowing hospitals
was signed on march 25th so for the
entire month of april just about
um patients were sent to nursing homes
to free up space while an entire
naval ship floated there unused
along with four other overflow hospitals
that were also barely used
how do you make sense of this granted
i don't know all the logistical
complications of sending patients into a
hospital ship but
whatever they are whatever extra effort
or red tape
had to be gone through whatever it would
be
wouldn't you make that effort rather
than intentionally introducing the virus
into communities of elderly people
so why weren't the ships used we can
only speculate here's one speculation
that you can't help but wonder about did
cuomo
choose to send the patients into nursing
homes rather than onto the ships because
he didn't want to have to say that trump
was helping
was this all about making sure that
trump didn't get credit
you can't help but wonder did 15 000
elderly
people die in order to protect cuomo's
political ego
now this possibility becomes even more
prominent when you consider another
big revelation this week this is from
the new york post this is what they
report governor andrew cuomo's top aide
privately apologized to democratic
lawmakers for withholding the state's
nursing home death toll from covet 19
telling them quote we froze out of fear
that the true numbers would be
used against us by federal prosecutors
the stunning admission of a cover-up was
made by secretary to the governor to the
governor melissa derosa
during a video conference call with
state democratic leaders in which she
said the cuomo administration
had rebuffed a legislative request for
the tally in august because quote
right around the same time president
donald trump turns this into a giant
political football
according to an audio recording of the
two-hour plus meeting
she continues he starts tweeting that we
killed everybody in nursing homes
derosa said he starts going after new
jersey governor phil murphy starts going
after california governor
newsom starts going after gretchen
whitmer
and the post report continues in
addition to attacking cuomo's fellow
democratic governors derosa said
trump directs the department of justice
to do an investigation into us
and basically we froze
okay if this is true for the new york
post and i see no reason to think that
it isn't
then we have an admission of a cover-up
and one of the worst cover-ups in
american history that's not an
exaggeration this is
easily without question one of the
country's deadliest political scandals
we're talking about decisions that were
made for political self-serving reasons
it would seem
that directly led to the deaths of
thousands of people
more from the post quote but instead of
a maya culpa to the grieving family
members of more than 13 000 dead seniors
or the critics who say
the health department spread cover 19 in
the care facilities with a march 25th
state health department directive
um derosa tried to make amends with the
fellow democrats for the political
inconvenience it caused them
she said so we do apologize i do
understand the position that we
that you were put in i know it's not
fair
it was not our intention to put you in
that political position with the
republicans
uh yes a political position with the
republicans
that's the concern here not you know all
the dead bodies
not the position you put your elderly
citizens in the position of
lying in a damned coffin well let's not
forget
while this was all going on um infected
patients sent into nursing homes
thousands of people dying a cover-up
habit
andrew cuomo the guy behind it all was
being awarded an emmy
for his press briefings and he signed a
book deal to brag about his coveted
leadership
and he was going on cnn for cutesy
interviews with his little brother
let's all remember this you know what i
understand this is the normal swab
i'm holding up here now and for
everybody at home
a very valuable object there's only one
company in the entire country
that makes these up in maine all right
here's the swap is it true
that this was the swab that the nurse
was actually using
on you and that at first it went
into your nose and disappeared so that
in scale this was the actual
swab that was being used to
fit up that double barrel shotgun that
you have mounted
on the front of your pretty face
see i said i was going to be nice and
sweet
i just wanted yes no and was it true i
was trying or was it this very hard
look which was it
oh isn't that so cute and sweet isn't
that so funny
you know in hindsight that's one of the
most embarrassing moments for the
american media
ever well not in hindsight it was
embarrassing at the time too
cuomo will continue to get this kind of
treatment from the media
no matter what's revealed about it
because they're invested in the
narrative
that trump and republican governors are
the ones who botched the coveted
response
that's the narrative they cannot waver
from it but the reality is clear
there's plenty of evidence that andrew
cuomo was guilty of criminal
negligence and rampant abuses of power
he should be arrested
prosecuted immediately maybe once
they're done with this
show trial in dc they'll get around to
that but i won't hold my breath
let's get now to our five headlines
i think maybe we can agree that there is
no benefit
no real silver lining to having acne
it's not anything anybody wants we can't
agree on much in society these days
this is one fact we can all unite around
you don't like having acne and that's
why you've got to try proactive
proactive combines gentle skin care
paired with the best acne treatment for
your skin proactive has three different
systems
designed for your skin type no matter
your type of breakout proactive combines
gentle skin care paired with the best
acne treatment for you
and they've got the three systems that i
mentioned they've got proactive md
advanced that's prescription strength
for stubborn breakouts they've also got
proactive plus
gentle which is for more gentle sort of
skin types and proactive solution
original
that's the original system it's suitable
for all skin types that's you know if
you don't know which one to grab you
just grab that one
and you go from there with clinically
proven ingredients and tested by
dermatologists
you get a simple three celsius
three-step system designed for you
and you can subscribe to consistently
clear clear skin
and that way you can clear up this
problem you don't have to live with it
right now is a great time to try
proactive
for our podcast listeners you can get a
special offer available by going to
proactive.com
walsh proactive subscribers will receive
the hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four hydrogel masks and
the green tea moisturizer
you also get free shipping again visit
proactive.com
waltz take advantage of this special
offer now that's proactive.com
walsh and subscribe to clearskin
yeah i just have to say i almost this is
something i almost talked about for the
daily cancellation but then something
else came along that annoyed me more and
so i'm doing that instead
but this is this is a something that has
plagued me for
for my whole life and it happened to me
again this morning when i was coming in
i was at the
stopping the gas station you know the
only thing worse
than someone who doesn't hold the door
for you when you're walking into a
building right behind them
is when somebody holds the door for you
when you're too far away
now i had i was at the gas station i was
practically just getting out of my car
like 25
paces away and this guy looks back sees
that i'm heading towards the door and
holds it for me
and i tried to give him the wave and say
no it's fine go ahead just keep just
keep going
and he gives me the way i'll stand here
and so now it's just that awkward walk
where i have to do that sort of half jog
walk to get to the
door faster than i otherwise would have
all for the sake of me not having to
just do this and open it myself
i'm perfectly capable of doing that you
could just keep going
so that is a lot worse and here's
because here's the mistake people make
and this is just the tip i'm going to
give you
walking inside a building it's a very
complicated procedure but here's what
you want to do because
if you're walking into the building and
then you look back
you do the check to make sure there's no
one coming in behind you if you catch
eye contact with someone coming in
behind you now you feel like you have to
hold it for them right
uh and even if they're 20 paces away so
make sure when you look
back your eyes are looking down so
you'll catch just their feet
and then you can make a judgment of how
many paces if it's more than 10 paces
you just keep going let them open the
door for themselves that's it
okay and at the end of the day if they
have to open the door for themselves
it's not a big deal
always err on the side
of being too rude than too polite
that's my tip that's my etiquette tip
take it or leave it you'll probably want
to leave it
okay um speaking of andrew cuomo he uh
and him embarrassing himself i also want
to play this for you number one
he shared a psa yesterday
from something called hip-hop public
health
i don't know what that is i don't know
why it is
but it is and uh well here it is
[Music]
[Music]
i will inspire time for us to trust and
not debate
the vaccine believe it's safe to take 9
out of 10 people won't get sick
that's 90 effective and legit discovery
thing is real and it will find you it's
killing our people let me
remind you back in the days back in the
days there was polio smallpox
bad enough that uh you know that's gonna
be really effective messaging
uh to the teens in 1988.
so if there's any teenagers in 1988
you know hanging around a back to the
future type of situation i think they're
going to be very
that that's something that they're going
to be really interested in it is just so
insulting though because because of
course
in reality they call this hip-hop public
health that's the organization
um this is obviously meant it's supposed
to supposed to speak to the black
community
and uh it's it's just so it's so
insulting
anytime you get these efforts by the
left or by the government
with messaging for a certain community
uh one community or another it's always
insulting
but if you want people people to get
vaccinated whether they're white black
otherwise
just just say so get give the info we
don't need the
the wrap we don't need run dmc of all
things
um just give give the information
i think someone regardless of their race
or ethnicity that's that's probably all
they're really looking for
i would assume
and you know information is actually
important not in the form of a wrap
but here's here are the facts about the
vaccine
because people have questions about it
it's okay to have questions
if you're asking millions of people to
inject something into their body
perfectly rational for them to have
questions
maybe just present that information in a
in a
in a way that is easy to understand
uh okay number two dave ramsey is
finding himself
in front of the cancellation firing
squad for his
comments on student loan forgiveness and
and also the stimulus
and he was trending yesterday uh because
people were very upset about this
and let's take a listen to his offensive
remarks and we'll decide if they really
are all that offensive
this is a political gimme by
progressives simply trying to buy votes
and we know that because when you go
from ten thousand in forgiveness to
fifty thousand in forgiveness
the people who benefit are not lower
income people
the vast majority of people that have an
average income or less
have less than ten thousand dollars of
student loan debt the vast majority of
people who would be blessed by moving it
from 10 to 50
are high income earners so again this is
all political rhetoric
it's not reality you come from an
interesting perspective you talk to
americans across the country every day
on your radio program
what what do you believe is the right
number or the right answer for
a for the next stimulus check
well i don't believe in a stimulus check
because if 600
or 1400 changes your life you were
pretty much screwed already
you've got other issues going on you
have a you have a career problem you
have a debt problem you have a
relationship problem you have a
mental health problem something else is
going on if 600 dollars changes your
life
and that's not talking down to folks
i've been bankrupt i've been broke and i
work with people every day who are
hurting i love people i want people to
be lifted up
but this is again it is it is just
political rhetoric and it's just
throwing dollars out there it's peeing
on a forest fire
okay so that's what people were crying
about which first of all agree or
disagree just the crying about it give
me a break
oh you're you're you're dog you're
talking down you're you're being
just shut up you're not actually
offended by that so stop it
we'll get to a point where people can
just express their opinion their point
of view
that's a it's a valid point of view in
fact
now i'm in favor of the stimulus as i've
said a million times because
just really on on principle more than
anything else
that the government has told people they
can't go to work and has shut down
entire industries and
and you know thousands of um of
businesses have gone over under because
of the government
and so they owe it they owe it if they
if if the government told you you can't
go to work or if they've destroyed
your business they owe you money
so it's not an entitlement now unlike
student loan forgiveness which was what
he was first talking about there now
that is like an entitlement
an entitlement in the sense in in the
way that that word has been used
historically in this country
which is that when we talk about
entitlements usually we're talking about
people getting money that they're not
actually entitled to so
uh with a stimulus the the irony is that
that actually another in another sense
in a very literal sense that is an
entitlement because you are actually in
this case entitled to it so
that all gets very confusing but um as
far as the stimulus goes
this is the government's fault for
shutting down the economy
and they owe it so that's my take on it
however however it's
also true that six hundred dollars
or twelve hundred dollars or two
thousand dollars
that's not gonna solve anybody's problem
if
if you've been bankrupted
or your business has been destroyed by
the lockdowns
then six hundred dollars even two
thousand dollars
that's that is
that's not even a band-aid
so it is a question how how many people
in the country right now
are in a position because of the
lockdowns
where they're really hurting but what
all they need is 1200 and 1200 bucks is
going to
is going to solve everything does anyone
fall into that category
i think there are a lot of people who
who've done okay
through the lockdown because their
industry wasn't that affected by it
that's the case by the way for the media
of which i'm i am in the media
um so there's a lot of people that are
that are doing fine or or they're in
another they're in another industry
where they could work from home that's a
lot of people
and they don't need the money they
shouldn't get anything a lot of them
will get money but they shouldn't
because they don't need it
if you haven't if you've if you have
been working through the pandemic
and have not taken a big hit in your um
in your paycheck
you should get zero dollars why should
you get anything
i think many of us have been in the
situation maybe especially recently
where you just feel like you can't get
ahead of your finances
it's not a fun situation to be in if
you've ever felt like no matter how hard
you work you just
can't seem to get ahead if you look back
past few years
and you feel like you know you never
have enough money in the bank or you
only have enough to pay your bills
and so you put it in it's like putting
it into a sieve and it just drains right
out again
that's not really the american dream is
it that's not what we're all hoping for
times are tough right now and a lot of
people have racked up all sorts of debt
whether it's credit cards consolidation
loans store cards even those payday
loans
that have a high interest rate over 100
percent life's been tough
but the good news is turbo debt is here
to help turbo debt is the solution to
these problems
banks want to keep you in debt that's
the fact they only make money uh when
you pay interest and so they have an
interest in you having to pay it
almost 70 percent of americans die with
credit card debt and no money in the
bank you don't want to be one of those
turbo debt helps with credit slash
retail cards
personal loans payday loans medical debt
all of that
they're going to help you out think
about how much you pay every month to
credit cards versus going into a bank
and savings
if you're paying 500 bucks a month at 6
000 a year in just five years
you would have thirty thousand dollars
in cash in the bank
if you didn't have these high interest
credit cards so if you have over ten
thousand dollars in credit card
personal loans medical or payday loans
they can help this is what you have to
do go to
turbo debt dot com slash wall that's
www.turbodebt.com
walsh for a free consultation
so if you're in that category you should
get anything but when you look at the
people who have been
legitimately devastated financially by
this
what is 600 or 1200 2 000 gonna do for
them
not much although i would say it's
better than nothing but the point is
the real thing that we can do for those
people is we get
the economy open you let people go back
to work you let restaurants
serve customers again and not with a
capacity of 10
or whatever crazy thing they're doing or
you have to feed them outside
like dogs um
that's the real solution but
his point there it's not it's not
unreasonable it's not irrational
if you're crying about it just get over
yourself
it look any time the government is
talking about spending
trillions of dollars it it's good for
people to criticize that even if you
agree with it
there should be an open debate there
should be no criticism
of a gov of a government spending bill
that's
out of bounds or out of line
uh the rest of what he said about about
the student loan forgiveness is 100
right
you know you talk about fifty thousand
dollars of student loan forgiveness who
who are the people who have fifty
thousand dollars of student loan debt
who are these people
are these are these for the most part
poor people with fifty thousand dollars
of student loan debt
or blue collar workers or you know
retail workers at
walmart no for the most part these are
upper income people and so it's that is
a bailout for
upper income privileged people that's
what a 50 000 student loan forgiveness
is so he's right about that too
all right um number three i just i want
to play this for you ron desantis
uh proving why he's our 2024 candidate
let's let's play this media is worried
about that obviously you guys really
love that
uh you don't care as much if it's a
quote peaceful protest then it's fine
you don't care as much if they're
celebrating a bite in election
you only care about if it's people that
you don't like so i'm a bucks fan
i'm damn proud of what they did on
sunday night
and so in terms of the uk variant here's
what we know
we know based on all the the evidence
that these vaccines are going to be
effective against that
and that's really the the main concern i
mean we're getting our seniors
vaccinated
uh we've not seen any data or any
evidence to suggest
that these vaccines are not effective
and so if we get the seniors vaccinated
we're going to be good and that's what
we're going to do if there's data that
comes out
not an academic model
yeah i guess i should have set that up a
little bit a little bit of framing there
uh he's he was responding to a question
about all of the the
bucks fans in florida that were out
celebrating
you know the victory and maybe they were
wearing a mask or maybe they weren't
and his response was exactly what you
just heard look well
i didn't hear you asking that about blm
protests you weren't talking about that
when people
were in the street that's the most
egregious thing of all
is when you when you think about the for
a couple of days
the biden fans in the street dancing and
celebrating
because there you don't have the excuse
with with the blm riots
the excuse we hear is that they were
they were protesting injustice and this
was something they had
that people had to do uh really they
were saying they're saving lives
actually in the end that's that's excuse
which of course completely bogus and
ridiculous
um with the biden celebrations though
you don't even have that
bogus and ridiculous excuse there's no
excuse
these are people that were happy because
their guy won and so they're out in the
street celebrating
no criticism from the media about that
that's a that's a good response you you
consistently hear ron desantis
uh responding to the media in exactly
the right way
saying the kinds of things in response
to their questions
that like you or i would say if we were
in that position
that's what i like about it okay uh so
that's someone responding the right way
to a thing here's someone
i think not responding the right way
morgan wallen
we know the country star who got himself
canceled after he was secretly recorded
by a neighbor
saying the n-word drunkenly to a friend
drunkenly and jokingly saying it and
next thing you know he's
he's his songs are kicked off of pretty
much every radio station in the country
uh he's he's not eligible for country
music awards anymore he's suspended by
his record label all this stuff is
happening
and he's already apologized for it he
apologized immediately
as soon as tmz got their hands on the
video
and they contacted morgan wild and he
immediately apologized
but that's not enough you know he
apologized it didn't have the effect he
was hoping
for probably and so here he is
apologizing again
hey y'all it's morgan
i'm long overdue to make a statement
regarding my last incident
i wanted to collect my thoughts seek
some real guidance and come to you with
a complete thought before i did
i was made aware of the video being
posted to tmz with
hardly any time to think before it was
released to the public
i was asked if i wanted to apologize and
of course i did
i wrote many detailed thoughts and only
a portion of those got used was painted
me in an even more careless light
i'm here to i'm here to hopefully show
you that that's not the truth
the video you saw was was me on hour 72
of 72 of a bender
and that's not something i'm proud of
either
obviously the the natural thing to do is
to apologize further and
just continue to apologize but because
you got caught
and that's not what i wanted to do
yeah i mean i guess i'm not going to
criticize them for
i think when you're in that position
it's hard to know
what are you supposed to say right what
do you he's already apologized
he's trying to apologize again uh so i
understand why he's
why he's doing it but at the same time
you know the
the problem is like we talked about
already this week the the people who are
calling for his cancellation and want
his career to be destroyed over this
and are celebrating over the fact that
it has effectively been destroyed at
least for now
uh there's there's just nothing you can
say to them it doesn't matter that
forgiveness is not part of the bargain
they don't
care because they don't care about the
initial offense
they weren't really offended by it nope
let me tell you
not one person in the country
was offended by that video of morgan
wallen nobody
you go online and try to find an example
of someone who appears to be actually
offended
no the reaction is we got him this is
going to take him down now
all right this is now we're going to
take this guy down it was like a
celebratory
vengeful kind of bloodlust
for most people it's they don't really
care one way or another
even if they are calling for his you
know for him to be fired and all this
kind of stuff
they don't really care there's no
passion in it it's just kind of casual
let's destroy another person for the
sake of it uh and then for but
as far as the passionate people it's
more it's it's vengeful
this is a guy you know he's he's a white
guy's country star
uh lives in nashville suspected trump
supporter even if he's not
he he kind of fits the bill and so yeah
we got him let's take him down that's
the attitude
um so there's there are there isn't any
injured party for you to apologize to in
reality
if there are people close to you in your
life who are actually disappointed maybe
people in your family
especially as he points out he was on a
bender you know all these kinds of
things maybe he's got family members or
personal friends who are really
disappointed by this then you speak to
them privately
you don't need to do it for the entire
world it's none of our business
it's not everybody in the public we
don't know morgan wallin we were not
involved in this
we're we're not injured by it if there
actually is anyone in his life who
he feels he needs to then you speak to
them maybe he's already done that that's
enough the apology does not need to be
put on display for everyone
so continuing to address it and
continuing to apologize it's just not
it's not going to have the desired
effect
because you're asking for grace and
forgiveness from people
who categorically deny will deny it they
will refuse it
no matter what you do
all right number five speaking of which
the daily beast is reporting on another
major racism scandal supposedly
um they say this is what they report
once again the bachelor is trying to
feel its way through a racism
controversy and this time it's not just
a
vexing contestant who's landed in hot
water but hosts chris harrison
as well on wednesday the bachelor guru
apologized for defending
rachel kirk connell after photos
surfaced of the season front-runner
attending a plantation-themed party now
i don't know who any of these people are
i've never watched the bachelor one time
in my life i don't know anything about
the original
controversy but this is what they say so
she attended a plantation themed party
kirk connell has already come under
scrutiny for apparently liking
racist social media posts now
big grain of salt there the daily beast
is saying that they're racist social
media posts maybe there were i have no
idea
but there's a very good chance they
weren't racist at all just because the
media calls something racist does not at
all mean that it was so
grain assault there um i'm not sure what
the social media posts were they could
have been anything
that's the thing with the media and the
left when they say the word racist you
just have
no clue what they're actually talking
about they could be referring to actual
racism
maybe 99 of the time the time though
they're not
so the word has lost meaning when they
use it
um as well as uh there were resurfaced
photos of her wearing a native american
halloween costume oh no
oh my god oh dear god she was wearing a
costume pretending to be
someone she's not on halloween that's
not the time for that
these posts are only more troubling
given that she's competing for the heart
of matt james the franchise's first
black bachelor
in nearly two decades on the air um well
why is that troubling
matt james maybe wanna maybe make let
him make decisions for himself
why is it troubling to you maybe you let
matt
james decide if he cares about the
native american costume or whatever
why would you be troubled uh during a
recent conversation with rachel lindsay
the first black bachelorette on extra
harrison seemed bent on convincing the
bachelor alum that really fans have been
too hard on kirk
um and so that's so that's it that's
that's what the host now is in trouble
for the host chris
chris harrison he's in trouble for
for saying this is him now he's
addressing it now he's apologizing
so he's apologizing
he was he was originally saying that we
should accept the apology of this other
person who has allegedly did a racist
thing
and now he has to apologize for that and
this is his apology for saying that we
should accept the other apology this is
what he says
to my bachelor nation family i will
always own a mistake when i make one so
i am here to extend a sincere apology
i have this incredible platform to speak
out about love and yesterday i took a
stance on topics about which i should
have been better informed
well i did not speak for rachel kirk
connell my intentions were simply to ask
for grace in offering her an opportunity
to speak on her own behalf
what i now realize i have done is cause
harm by wrongly speaking in a manner
that perpetuates racism and for that i
am so deeply sorry
no you haven't caused any harm you um
chris
whatever your name is again chris
harrison you've caused
no harm to anyone nobody has been harmed
nobody's been harmed by
comments that the host of the bachelor
made
um about some other controversy
remember what i said about morgan wallin
forgiveness and grace are ruled out
you are not going to get it from the
cancel mob well here here
here this proves that point exactly now
chris harrison
is being cancelled simply for saying we
should have grace and forgiveness for
someone else
absolutely not to even call for grace
and forgiveness
is itself racist now
but that won't stop this guy from
apologizing and uh another apology that
will be
absolutely ignored okay um
where do we read the youtube comments in
a second oh yeah but one other thing
here's a bonus
this is from a local news report i
wanted to play this for you it's a great
video
almost as good as the cat lawyer not
quite as good but almost as good
here's a mother proving why she should
be the first nfl player
not sarah fuller let's watch this a
police officer's dash cam
rolling when a houston area mother
tackles a suspected peeper
who she says was looking into her
daughter's bedroom
even if you think you can run from the
cops good luck getting past this mom
captured on police dash cam taking down
a man she says was trying to look into
her 15 year old daughter's bedroom
window
early on a sunday that is a nice tackle
i got to say that's good form tackle
she plants the shoulder i especially if
you're on the chief's defense especially
in the
defensive backfield after the
performance we saw in the super bowl you
could take some tips from this
you see what she does first of all she
wraps up okay she's not just
throwing her body into the guy she's
going for the full wrap up you see how
she wraps
her arms around his body and look at her
shoulder look where her shoulders place
now this is great form
she she plants the shoulder into his
chest
okay now you could argue she's hitting
him a little high she could go a little
bit she could go a little
you know maybe maybe bend the knees a
little bit more um
but still i say pretty good form
and a great pursuit angle that's the
other thing you got to consider as a
defender
you got to take the right angle and you
see how she she squares up
and she takes this angle and boom she
gets them
that is a great tackle i love that
that's a heartwarming video you gotta
love to see that
uh and the thing is everybody loves that
right you see that you see a mother
defending her daughter
taking this guy down and it just it
warms your heart to see it doesn't it
whether it's whether it's a mother or
father it warms your heart why does it
work you know it's worth thinking about
like why do we love seeing a video like
that
because this is this is a this is
motherly
love properly ordered okay she's she's
going to defend
her daughter and we all love to see that
we love to see mothers and fathers
doing what mothers and fathers do that
properly ordered
familial love we love we we all enjoy
seeing that
and that's worth thinking about when you
consider for example the black lives
matter
movement saying they want to um destroy
the nuclear family
well that's what they're trying to
destroy right there
all right let's move on to read our
youtube comments we got a bunch of
comments on the show
yesterday we won't read all of them but
a few um
this is from ffvi girl
she says hey matt i signed up with
charity mobile so far so good thank you
for the recommendation
and thank you thank you for supporting
the sponsors of this show um that's
that's something that
that i certainly appreciate and they
appreciate as well shayna silker says
matt two things
one i agree with you on so much but
would have to disagree about star wars
being overrated
save uh the three movies that came out
in early 2000s those can just go away
number two as a pregnant woman who
already can't breathe in one mask i hope
you wrong
i hope you're wrong on the pattern of
the cdc making it required to wear two
masks
love what you guys are doing yeah well
on this on star wars being overrated
listen
how many star wars movies have there
been and how many have actually been
good
at most you can argue that the first
three were good i i i don't
i think they that your your judgment on
the first three
is skewed by your nostalgic attachment
to them
but even if i were to agree that they're
good
you've got what nine movies and
a third of them arguably are okay
i think that qualifies as overrated
lobster puncher
another great username says i don't know
what lobsters ever did to him but
matt walsh prohibits his subjects from
using emojis also matt walsh
cold opens with a cat filter his ways
are not our own i don't know what you're
referring to what cat filter are you
talking about i have no idea
aaron hamner says the left wants strong
beautiful intelligent and courageous
women
unless they disagree with their views
what a petty group of fascists
that's exactly right they want they want
women to be strong
and independent uh girl
power all of that until the moment comes
when a woman expresses a viewpoint that
they disagree with in which case
destroy her that's the way that we know
of course that's how it always that's
how it always works
um bill berger says
matt a guy in a stairwell this morning
screamed at me to maintain a six feet
distance as i came closer to him and
while he was climbing up towards me
a stairwell in a public building we both
had masks on
and i said to him and laughed that it
would be coming to that at some point
if it could happen it will he screamed
at me after i passed him
going uh down the up down the stairwell
six feet distancing you jackass i hope
you get covered the wheels are not
coming off america they've been off for
a long time
i hope you get yeah it is funny how
quickly
the real the the very paranoid people
pro maskers it's it's funny how quickly
they go from
i'm wearing a mask to protect you to
protect to protect you
they go from that to if you don't wear a
mask i hope you die
you know they go from i'm trying to
protect you to i hope you die
in like one second flat which should
tell you something about the pro mask
message chrissy jensen finally says so
you say to get your kids out of public
schools but also you want the schools to
open
seems like maybe you should be
celebrating the public schools aren't
teaching
it's kind of like your shoe cancellation
you don't want to see our feet but also
you cancelled shoes hashtag there is no
winning
everything is bad well i don't disagree
with your hashtags but
yes ultimately as a society
i think we should move away from public
schools
ultimately i think we should get the
government out of the education business
because they've done such a poor job of
it
and i don't think that's just something
the government should be doing period i
don't think that's something we should
rely on the government to do
um so that's ultimately and i've been
saying that for years
but that's a gradual change you have to
make as a society
you you can't do it all at once because
then disaster unfolds
it's not fair to the families it's not
fair to the kids and the other important
thing is
if we're getting rid of the government
school system you got to replace it with
something
i never said there should be no
education and what's happening now
is that we have effectively suspended
the government school education for
for a year and replaced it with nothing
for a lot of these kids
because zoom class is nothing it amounts
to nothing
so rather than kids being educated in
the public school system they're just
not being educated at all
and on top of having no other social
interaction not being around their
friends being isolated and all these
things
so yes while i while i think that
society should move that way
this is not the way to do it
and besides whatever my opinions are the
public school system
the fact that i'm a homeschool advocate
that doesn't change the fact the
teachers who are refusing to go to work
and and do their job are despicable and
should be called out for it
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
one thing you hear from business owners
is that hr
issues when you're when you're when
you're starting a business or you have a
business
hr issues are the issues that can really
kill you wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap
either we're talking about an average of
seventy thousand
dollars a year that's why you need bambi
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e was created
specifically for small businesses to
address this problem you get it you can
get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy maintain your compliance all for
just 99
a month with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone
email real time chat this is somebody
working for you
from onboarding determination they
customize your policies to fit your
business and they help you manage your
employees day-to-day
all for just 99 a month month to month
no hidden fees cancel any time
there's no risk involved here so you got
to try it out let bambi help
get your free hr audit today uh you can
just you can at least go get the hr
audit go to bambi.com walsh right now to
schedule your free hr audit that's
bambi.com
walsh spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh and next up
please join me in a special edition of
my daily cancellation featuring disney
plus
and their long list of double standards
more excitingly this cancellation comes
with some bitty
some pretty big news i think the daily
wire just announced
that we'll be making a movie with gina
carano the mandalorian actress that
disney just cancelled
her crime disagreeing with woke
hollywood
pretty unbelievable times we're living
in right now so uh you know you could
lose your job for being an independent
thinker that's what it comes down to
but added to the list i guess this was a
classic disney happily ever after
public display of contempt for
conservative opinions the irony however
is whether hollywood realizes it or not
they're just encouraging conservatives
to be more active
in the film space their film space we
launched run hide fight last month and
we're very excited to have gina on board
with us
for what's next on the entertainment
slate effective now she'll be working
with the daily wire to develop produce
and star in an upcoming film to be
released exclusively to members
that's pretty exciting uh stay tuned for
more movie details over at dailywire.com
and get 25
off your membership today with code gina
we already got the code ready for you
don't miss out on any content go to
dailywire.com wall subscribe and use
code gina to get 25
off your daily wire membership that's
g-i-n-a
for 25 off today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
today we're going to cancel variety uh
the the magazine variety and also carrie
mulligan
who's an actress who i actually thought
was pretty good in the one thing i saw
her in
unless i'm thinking of something else i
don't know anyway to understand how this
cancellation came about we must reach
back in time all the way back to january
of 2020.
so back then a year ago a film critic
named dennis harvey wrote a review for a
variety
of carrie mulligan's new new film which
is called promising young woman
now that movie according to imdb is
about quote a young woman traumatized by
a tragic event in her past
who seeks out vengeance against those
who crossed her path
not exactly revolutionary stuff from the
sound of it but that's all right
the film critic harvey basically liked
the movie
but thought that some element elements
of it didn't quite work specifically he
thought that mulligan's performance
was maybe a little bit off okay here's
what he said
mulligan a fine actress seems a bit a
bit of an odd choice as this admittedly
many layered apparent femme fatale
margot robbie is a
producer here and one can perhaps too
easily imagine the role might once have
been attended for her
whereas with this star cassie wears her
pickup bait gear like bad
drag even her long blonde hair seems a
put on
the flat american accent she delivers in
her lowest voice register likewise seems
a bit meta
though it's not quite clear what the
quote marks around this performance
signify
still like everything here this turn is
skillful entertaining and challenging
even when the eccentric method obscures
the precise message
that's what he said now you might hear
that and think
how dare this man critique that poor
woman i mean you might think that if
you're a stupendous [ __ ] who doesn't
understand that critiquing is literally
the whole
job of the critic so it seems that
mulligan herself
did not understand this or pretended not
to understand it and whether whether
what comes next is the result of her
being a stupendous [ __ ] or just a petty
ridiculous bully is up to you to decide
i tend to think it's more the latter
what happened is that a year later in an
interview with the new york times
published with the title carrie mulligan
won't let hollywood off the hook
mulligan complained about that variety
review which again at this point was a
year ago
and she's still thinking about it she
said quote
i read the variety review because i'm a
weak person mulligan said
and i took issue with it she paused
debating whether she really wanted to go
there
it felt like it was basically saying
that i wasn't hot enough to pull off
this kind of ruse
she said finally mulligan can still
recite some of the lines from that
review
but she said it wasn't some sort of
ego-wounding thing like i fully can see
that margot robbie is a
goddess what bothered mulligan most was
that people
might read a high-profile critique of an
actress's physical appearance and
blindly accept it
it drove me so crazy i was like really
for this film you're gonna write
something that is so transparent
now in 2020 i just couldn't believe it
yes a film critic criticizing in 2020
unbelievable no carrie what's
unbelievable
or perhaps all too believable is that
you were
roundly praised and celebrated for your
performance in this dumb movie
and one guy offers a mild descent and
you stew over it for a year
and then smear him as a misogynist
that's the part that stands out to me
the only part of mulligan's diatribe
that i agree with is that she says she's
a weak person
now that is clearly true but weak people
can still be bullies in fact they often
are
and that's what she's doing here she is
bullying
and she didn't stop a couple of months
later she was doing an interview
or a discussion with another actress and
in fact she was doing this for varieties
she
this is this was filmed by variety and
published on their platform
and in this discussion she still
couldn't shut up about the one film
critic who sort of criticized her one
time let's take a listen i know recently
you called out a movie review
and their criticism and saying that it
was sexist and they ended up apologizing
for it and i just wanted you to kind of
speak to that and and what that really
meant for you i feel it's important that
you know we the criticism is is
um it's constructive i think it's
important that we
uh are looking at the right things when
it comes to work and we're looking at
the art and we're looking at the
performance and
you know the way that a film is made um
and i don't think that that
goes to the appearance of an actor or
your personal
preference for um what an actor does or
doesn't look like
i think in criticizing or bemoaning a
lack of attractiveness on
my part in a character it wasn't a
personal slight it wasn't something that
i felt
it didn't wound my ego but it made me
concerned that
in such a big publication an actress's
appearance could be criticized and it
could be
you know that could be accepted as
completely um
reasonable okay so she's concerned she's
very concerned
uh very she's just she's just cuz you're
not worried about herself that's why
that's not why she's stewing over this
review for a year and a half uh it's not
that she's concerned
um it's it's that she's uh it's not
about herself right it's
she's looking out for everybody else and
all the women out there that's what this
is about
everything she's saying about the review
was completely wrong of course he didn't
say that she isn't hot enough
he was talking and he's by the way the
reviewer is a gay man so
uh it's probably unlikely that he would
be judging her on that basis anyway
he was talking about the way that she
inhabited and embodied the role
this is a very common thing for critics
to bring up
for both men and women aka mulligan says
it's not about your personal opinion
about
of course it's about his personal he's a
critic that's all it's about it's about
his opinion
now how far that opinion goes with you
how much you care about his opinion
that's a different subject
personally i don't care about the
opinion of a film critic hardly at all
but
either way that's what he does
men and women anytime a new batman is
cast we hear about this kind of
discussion
uh we always hear this kind of
discussion you know nobody's asking
whether the actor is hot enough to be
bruce wayne but
but we're asking whether he has the
physical presence to pull off that role
you hear that all the time for male
roles that was harvey's point
any semi-literate person can understand
that
so is mulligan illiterate or is she just
an enormous egomaniac
those would seem to be our two options
we could ask the same questions about
the um
the illiteracy of the powers that be at
variety
because after hearing that an actress
didn't enjoy being critiqued by their
film critic
they tacked on an editor's note on to
the one-year-old review which says now
now if you go to that review here's what
it says right at the top editor's note
variety sincerely apologizes to kerry
mulligan and regrets the insensitive
language and insinuation in our in our
view
of promising young woman that minimized
her daring performance
yes they apologized for allowing the
film critic
they employ to criticize her
they also called her performance daring
in the editor's note as if it's some
sort of objective
fact it's not in fact i haven't seen the
movie but i can say right now
definitively there is nothing daring
about it
an actress playing a woman seeking
vengeance in a performance that received
near universal praise
is not daring might have been a good
performance
but daring no an abc news reviewer being
a good boy and saying only what he's
allowed to say
called the movie quote a diabolically
funny takedown of toxic masculinity
now maybe he's right that it's
diabolically funny i don't know um i
haven't seen it but what i can say for
sure is that there is nothing at all
even a bit
daring about a hollywood film trying to
take down toxic masculinity
that's not daring at any rate um
maybe that's a minor detail the greater
point is that a film critic was attacked
as a misogynist for doing his job
and his publication caved like a
sinkhole and threw him under the bus
we should note also that the national
society of film critics
did come out and defend the critic
dennis harvey but it took them two
months to do it
because even the society of film critics
has to spend two months
working up the nerve to defend the
concept of
being a film critic and you would think
that if the society of film critics has
any function at all that's it
this is the world we live in now the
power of victimhood knows no bounds
it can even exempt an actress from
criticism by film critics
it is a get out of jail free card quite
literally in many cases and also a get
out of criticism card
get out of accountability card get out
of any unpleasant situation card
people like kerry mulligan know that
they know that they have this card
they know the power that comes with it
and they're eager to play it
the only way this ever changes is if we
get to a point
as a society where we can look at
somebody like carrie mulligan
and say listen okay listen lady i
understand your feelings are hurt
however your feelings are unreasonable
your point of view is ridiculous
you're being obnoxious you are not owed
an apology and you will not get one
get over yourself
that must be the response to these
self-victimizing manipulative bullies
until we until we start responding that
way this
will never change but
at least i can still say to carrie
mulligan and variety
you are cancelled
last one for the week many more to come
though and we'll wrap it up
there now have a great weekend everybody
talk to you next week
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin
[Music]